in just a few days comedian Bill Cosby
goes on trial for a second time accused
of aggravated indecent assault on former
Temple University employee andrea
constand more than a decade ago
Cosby's first trial ended last June when
a jury couldn't decide whether the 80
year-old drugged and assaulted constan
leading to a mistrial here to preview
what's ahead in the case is CBS News
legal analyst Ricky Clayman Ricky good
morning morning the environment has
changed since that trial to say the
least
yes he was happening the trial changes
the trial completely changes you have to
understand that he was tried last June
the me2 movement as a result of the
dominoes falling from ales to a Riley to
Weinstein etc that all happened really
and blossomed in the fall of 2017 so
what changes for Bill Cosby at the time
of the original trial that was looked at
that you had basically the one-and-only
word of this accuser Andrea constant
bullied up by one other accuser and in
that world we believed collectively as
society that we were skeptical of one
woman's word about an assault that a
indecent assault that occurred years ago
without more well now me too now the
presumption has totally changed it's
exactly the inverse we believe that in
accusation by a woman whether or not
corroborated
must be truthful and here now we're
going to have lots of women who are
going to support her if Bill Cosby had
tried this case for the second time in
October early in October it would be
different than now we're also going to
hear from more women in this case more
women indeed the first trial as I said
one now come from five the prosecution
had asked for a total of 19 other
accusers the defense said it would be
unduly prejudicial they wound up with
the judge ruling that five could come in
was as bad as 19 it is for the defense
why is he allowing five this time well
he decided that when he looked at the
rule the rule says you cannot try person
on character propensity to act just
because they did something once doesn't
mean
that we should listen to other times to
about that what he decided is under rule
404 which is a universal rule but in
Pennsylvania that there are exceptions
to this rule that you don't allow what
we call prior bad acts or uncharged
misconduct and one of those exceptions
means that it was a signature that what
he did and we had a common scheme or
plan a motor 7mo as they say in
thrillers and so this mo was to drug
women and then to take sexual advantage
of them
when they were unable to consent so five
are coming in there five of the more
recent even though they go back to the
80s let's count that the 80s they this
is a win obviously for the prosecution
and getting them to be on the stand
but the defense won a couple motions
that could also play a role as well yes
they did and this is a new trial first
of all they have a new lawyer they have
Tom Mesereau Tom Mesereau by the way
Robert Blake Fame Michael Jackson frame
and in michael jackson there were also
five other accusers so keep that in mind
so here what the defense also won goes
to their theory of the case the defense
is not doing this was a romantic
consensual relationship which is how the
first trial was the defense's portraying
or is going to attempt to portray Andrew
a constant the accuser as a greedy woman
who was willing to frame Bill Cosby how
do they intend to do that
they got a ruling that says that her
settlement which is purported to be some
3.5 million dollars that that is coming
in did not come in the first time and
that she was in it for the money how
else do they do it they have a witness
named Marguerite Jackson Margo Jackson
Miss Jackson is going to testify
allegedly that Andrea said to her that I
am going to frame a celebrity and get
money it's gonna be a very interesting
case ridiculous I'll be back with you
every day thank you thanks for being
here